i'm heath borders i'm the
mobile technical lead at jive software
um
and i'm at heathport on twitter this is
make your apps accessible to all
so in this talk we're going to have
actually two talks in one um we're going
to
discuss uh simple android accessibility
and we're going to access
simple or address simple and complex
iphone accessibility we're also going to
talk about how to
build what's called third party
accessibility services for android those
are
super cool so on the iphone
accessibility falls under the ui
accessibility
series of functions that's in ui
accessibility.h
basically builds a separate dom
hierarchy
for your uiview dom that
is accessible to screen readers and so
essentially the screen reader
introspects your dom
and presents that to the user uh usually
for our cases and what we're dealing
with with most of this talk is we're
going to
be dealing with audio feedback for
visually impaired users
so as you can see we're it's going to
break down this
this simple ui into a series of
accessibility elements for uh buttons
static text
and those are the those are the trait
names we're going to get into that a
little bit
ui accessibility was introduced in ios
3. this was actually like an a
a major groundbreaking event for for
mobile os's that had had no hard
keyboards so this is actually ios has
turned into
one of the best os's for for users that
need excessive
accessibility technologies despite the
fact that it has basically no hard
buttons
um there's been new apis every major
release most of what we're going to deal
with
was introduced in ios 5.
uh so as i said the uh what the
except what your accessibility elements
actually do are defined by
uh ui accessibility traits and so that
is basically a
large bit mask that defines i think 17
different things that individual
accessibility elements can do so for the
most part for simple user interfaces
you're really only going to be dealing
with
with accessibility trade button
accessibility traits
static text static text is what a label
turns into
and so if you're doing if you have uh
things that aren't labels like if you're
using core text
to render to draw and render custom text
then you would want to
declare your declare your accessibility
element to
be a a type of static text
um there's lots more you can go into the
go into the ui accessibility traits
headers in
in xcode and and review them
what's very nice about ui accessibility
on the iphone is that it provides
a really sensible default so
when you are when you're coding up your
user interface
or you're building an xcode you can get
a lot of
the a lot of ui accessibility uh
functionality for free
so basically any uh any ui control so
again just a quick refresher in ui kit
there is there are ui views which are
the
uh that's the sub the super class of all
types within
all types that are added into the ui
view or the ui view dom hierarchy
directly under that is the ui control
subclass and all ui controls are
automatically accessibility elements by
default
and they get very nice accessibility
traits and
they are very easily introspected by the
screen reader
it's really easy you just get all that
stuff for free and the
and a user can can explore them very
easily
if you have things like a ui label or a
ui image view that are not ui controls
it's really easy to turn them into
accessibility elements
and basically all you have to do is just
set is accessibility element to yes so
the reason you would want to do this is
that then the ui label or uiimageview
becomes a navigable part of your
hierarchy so if your label is an
important
piece of content if you've got a big
label on your page and you want the user
to be able to navigate to it and read it
then you want to make it accessible so
that they can touch the element
with the screen reader um and what's
also very nice is that ui
or ui image view provides a very nice
default based on the file name of the ui
image that you used so
i don't necessarily recommend doing this
uh as your
as your accessibility strategy but what
is nice about it is that it's just that
much easier you can literally just
set as accessibility element to yes and
you at least get something
and that's as we're gonna see in android
that's that's better than what android
provides
at least the at least the user can can
make some kind of determination even if
it's not the best
scenario now under normal usage
basically you're only going to ever
override a maximum of
three of four things but really you're
probably only gonna ever override is
accessibility element and accessibility
label
this is what it looks like in xcode it's
part of the attributes tab
and there's just an accessibility
section and essentially you're just
going to
to set is accessibility element you'll
just check the enabled button
and boom you have an accessibility
element in your ui um
the accessibility label is supposed to
be a
one word or ideally one word very short
description
of the accessibility element the screen
reader is going to read this to the user
as they navigate the page potentially
it could read all of depending on the
abilities of the user it might read
the entire ui from top to bottom so you
don't want to make the user have to wait
while you while you enumerate a 10 word
description of what your button does
that's what the accessibility hint is
for the accessibility hint describes the
actual
uh the actual purpose of the element in
greater detail
so for and and we'll get into an example
of that but like for a
music app you might have a play label
and then you'd have the hint could be
starts playing the music
and the value then is this is if it's a
stateful
element so if it's a button you can say
well it's selected it's not
or uh you can get into more complex use
cases and of course then you can add
many many more traits these are you know
again some of the
some of the other traits you can you can
drop in place so as a concrete example
of this this is from the maps app and
these are the real values the maps app
uh the maps app uses so for the tracking
button down here
excuse me for the tracking button down
here you've got
uh late the label is tracking
and the hint is activate to change
tracking options that hint doesn't
change
uh because the the button is still the
it
it still performs the same action but
then as you
uh as you activate the button it's it
cycles through its different values and
so you can continuously introspect the
button
and get what values it has it'll go
between off on and
on with heading of course
so uh voiceover is the name of the
screen reader
that's used actually i believe it's the
name of the screen reader in uh
in os 10 as well but it is the one and
only screen reader for ios it's baked
into the system
you can get to it via settings general
accessibility voiceover
i highly recommend that at a minimum you
just turn this on and play around with
it and see
what kind of experience your user is
going to have it's actually
if you're not used to it it can be kind
of annoying but it it uh
it's actually not that hard to use and
it doesn't take very long to get pretty
good at working with it and
you could really do a whole talk on just
how to how to properly interact with
voiceover
the really essential thing for
developers is to set up an accessibility
shortcut
so within the voiceover options there's
a there's the
setup accessibility shortcut option and
you can do a number of different
things you can turn on zooming you can
turn on
lots of other lots of other different
options but i recommend
just enabling and disabling voiceover
with it and with that then you can
easily in the middle of your testing
triple click home and
and navigate through the app and make
sure that that it's
behaving as expected uh and this link
right here apple has a fondness for
ridiculously long links into their
documentation this actually goes through
a great detail of all the different
gestures that are available and the
slides are going to be public and i've
also got a big list of links at the end
of the page don't worry about trying to
write this down because it's hopeless
um but you'll be you'll be able then to
uh to discover all there's a lot of
different gestures for
uh obviously navigating forward backward
going through individual characters of
individual labels things like that it's
it's pretty impressive what you can do
with voiceover unfortunately on the ios
simulator you've really got
no access to voiceover at all what you
do have is the ince
accessibility inspector and so the
accessibility inspector is there just
to provide you access to the
access the values that you set on your
accessibility element so you can kind of
can
think of this as like spot based mock
testing for voice over so you know that
you can know that
the values that you expect to be on your
control are actually validated so that's
helpful if you have
uh dynamically generated labels values
hints
whatever most uh most helpfully
is for uh is for debugging uh
dynamically generated accessibility
elements which we're going to get into a
little bit later in the talk
for mo for more complex uh views
like ui webview voiceover is going to
find web accessible elements
automatically and again web
accessibility is a whole that's a whole
nother talk and that's
that's a big topic just into itself but
you can look that up
at the web accessibility initiative on
w3.org
and they've got lots of good stuff in
there you you can with most
existing web toolkits just get
accessibility for free i know that
digit and jquery mobile both implement
wai standards
i'm sure that your favorite reputable
web toolkit does something similar
for simple ui table views you do not
want to
change is accessibility as accessibility
excuse me
is accessibility element explicitly on
ui labels
so again is accessibility element make
marks
and marks a control as being a part of
the accessibility hierarchy and that
means it's something that can be focused
the all the accessibility elements are
also leaves
of the accessibility dom and what that
means is that the user is no longer
going to be able to navigate to your
cell within the table
and most of the time when you uh you
want users to be able to navigate to the
cell so they can select the cell like in
mail
if you marked the subject line of an of
an email as an accessibility label then
they never be able to touch the
actual mail cell and they'd never
actually be able to navigate
into the mail so that's bad ui ui table
view cell actually provides very nice
sensible defaults for this it actually
just builds the accessibility label
out of all of the child ui labels that
exist within the cell so
you can just that's actually pretty nice
and gives you
most of the time what you actually want
but you can override this by overriding
accessibility label on ui table view
cell or by setting it directly if you
want
uh for oops sorry wrong way for uh
simple ui collection views
cell navigation doesn't work out of the
box that's because for unlike uh ui
table views
ui collection views are a really complex
beast and it's not really clear
what are there there are uh supplemental
views but you never really know with a
ui collection view
whether something is decorative or
whether something is really important
content for the user
so you need to explicitly uh mark a ui
collection view cell as being an
accessibility element
and then that will provide you want to
do it at the cell level
not necessarily not at the um
not at the sub view within the
collection the
ui collection view cell level because
you'll have the same problem that you
get with ui table view cells where you
won't be able to select the actual cell
and then your your selection logic won't
run
so now we're going to get into the cool
stuff which is
with ui accessibility container you can
build dynamic
ui accessibility elements and
and this is useful for really complex uh
custom controls
so if you have either either a complex
control or something that
that has a lot of is a single very rich
content control if you had a map for
example if we were going to build a
a control that showed the layout of the
strange loop conference you would want
to have individual sections you wouldn't
want to just be an image but you'd want
to have
individual rectangles of the of the map
reflect
certain named areas and that's what ui
accessibility container is going to
allow us to do it's going to allow us to
mark off certain regions
of a view as being as having important
accessibility elements
and then we're going to use we use ui
accessibility notifications
to build these um except to build these
accessibility
elements and so that way or sorry to
notify
the screen reading system that uh that
the
uh layout of our ui accessibility dom
has changed
and so that way we can we can
make sure that voiceover is updating the
current state
to the user uh so that then they can go
and re
and re-navigate the page and make sure
that
everything uh you know that they they
can gain new context so they can have
uh voiceover reread things top to bottom
for them
so uh we're gonna we're gonna post uh u
accessibility post notification can
actually be used for a lot of different
notifications that
you can post but for our purposes for
most custom controls
all we really need to do is post either
layout change notification which is for
very small changes this is for things
like having a control
appear or disappear on the screen
if you don't do this then what ends up
happening is the
uh when the user taps in the area even
though there's nothing on the screen
they're still going to
see it as being there so this is again
one of the reasons why it's important to
actually test this way
with your users and or with with
voiceover for your users and that way
you can make sure that
you're getting the same context that
your accessibility
using users will have then also you have
a ui accessibility screen change
notification
this is for really big changes if you
did something that blew away the whole
screen
if you change the view controller you
and usually these things are going to
get fired automatically for you when the
view controllers change but if you have
some kind of a
a uh you know if you're if you have a
fully
drawn custom view for a game or
something and you just change the whole
game board then you want to
fire off ui accessibility changed and
that'll go through and rescan the entire
the entire dom so
now we're gonna get into a demo this is
uh this is just a very simple
uh a very simple single control that i
wrote that demonstrates all this
functionality so
uh ordinarily if you were going to
implement something like this
that red the red and the orange kind of
look exactly the same on that screen
that's unfortunate
so this is actually we've actually got
four different four different
rectangles here red orange yellow green
and
ordinarily you could just implement
those as four buttons but just
just to illustrate this point further i
this is actually just one ui view
that's then dynamically drawn using draw
rect and then
when you do a uh when you do a touch up
inside
i'm actually tracking that with touches
ended so that uh then
i can pop up a uh accessibility or a
ui alert view to say where you touched
so then we'll just have a little video
just to demonstrate this in action for
a a normally abled user
top right button oh sorry this is the
sorry this is the this is what it's
going to look like with voiceovers so
this is where
i'm actually just navigating i'm just
going to you can kind of imagine what
it's going to look like just without
voiceover turned on so this is with
voiceover turned on
and what this is going to do then if let
me turn the sound up a little bit as
well because you can't really hear it
very well
it's going to speak it's going to speak
the names of each quadrant so you're
going to hear top
right top bottom right top left bottom
left etc
top right button bottom right button
bottom left button top left button
hjb accessibility and real quick right
there you notice that i didn't type
directly or i didn't tap directly on
the element that was selected that's
because uh the
invoice over to perform a selection you
just have to double tap anywhere on the
screen
okay button top left
button
now notice that i just rotated the
device but all of my
uh now when i navigate again all of the
different uh
quadrants are going to be updated with
the with appropriate rectangle
boundaries and so we're still going to
get uh we're still going to get the
appropriate controls
portrait
top left button bottom left button
bottom right
button top right button
and so then we'll just go ahead and jump
into the code that we used to do this
so uh within my ui view and you'll
you'll forgive me if i've got multiple
slides since
if any of us are our iphone developers
objective-c is a really really verbose
language so you'll forgive me if i
if i'm not so terse um within my view i
have a single
update accessibility elements method and
this is where i build out all the the
rectangles
that uh that reflect where on where
within the view
the actual um the actual accessibility
elements are
so essentially this is just very simple
ui kit
math right here i'm taking this screen
and i'm taking the bounds of my view and
i'm dividing it in half
top and bottom and then i divide the top
and bottom halves again
left and right this is the important
part here is i'm building out the
accessibility frames
now when you build the excessive when
you're declaring the accessibility
frames for
a ui accessibility element you need to
make sure that your
elements are in screen coordinates and
that's just a requirement of ui
accessibility element so
to do that you use the convert rect
method
on your view and you make sure to
convert it to a view of nil
and so that will that will put your
coordinates in screen coordinates so now
i've got
the four uh rectangles that i that
represent my individual frames
and so then i can go through and build
out i'm just going to show you how i
build an
individual accessibility element it's
pretty simple i
just i just knew it up with my
accessibility with its parent
accessibility container that's how it
built that's how we build up the dom
and then i simply declare its label
declare its frame
and whatever traits so in this case it's
a button that that's how we get our
button-like behavior that's how we know
it's selectable
and i'm going to declare the other three
in very similar ways
then i'm just assigning it to my to an
array that i'm tracking in my class
this is the last important step i want
to make sure that i that i actually have
a window before i uh post my
notification you don't want to be posted
you're gonna you're gonna negatively
impact the user if you're constantly
firing off spurious
layout change notifications if you if
you don't have a window yet that means
that you're not actually part of the ui
kit hierarchy which means that you're
not
part of you can't possibly be part of
the screen so there's no reason to fire
off your
your ui accessibility notification so i
just checked for that
and then finally we have the this is the
actual important code this is the code
that we
uh that we need to implement as part of
it as a member of
or as a subclass of ui view to allow
voiceover to pull our accessibility
notification
or accessibility element children so
first thing we do is we override his
accessibility element to no
again as i mentioned before ui
accessibility element is the
leaf of the dot of the accessibility dom
tree and what that means is that
none of the none of the accessibility
containers can that can themselves be
accessibility elements
if your accessibility container is an
accessibility element then
then voiceover will not navigate any
further down trying to find
your uh trying to find child
accessibility elements then these two
methods are
really or these next three are really
pretty simple you just basically
delegate them out to your containing uh
array so i've got an accessibility
element count obviously
the element index this is this is a
little bit different we don't delegate
directly to the array because
the uh the contract says that if the
if a accessibility element is requested
out of bounds you need to return
nil and not blow up and nsra will will
throw an exception and crash your app if
you request one out of bounds
and uh index of accessibility element
this is uh just it's okay to return and
it's not found if you uh
if you don't have one uh
finally then we got some we've got some
more uh more advanced
uh sort of uh medium medium advanced
uh accessibility uh apis so these are
for if you're building a
uh accessibility element increment and
decrement these are
methods that you override directly on
your ui view and these are for things
like if you have a slider
or anything that is adjustable you can
you can support direct adjustability
that's because some hardware actually
has
has direct buttons on it and that's
going to enter that's going to interact
with bluetooth with ios and it'll allow
users to directly adjust things up and
down so
this just gives direct access to that
similarly
for similarly for accessibility scroll
this is for custom scroll views
and that's i i actually haven't
implemented a custom scroll view with ui
accessibility yet but
it's a very it's actually a pretty
complex uh piece to deal with as
i mentioned there's other there are
other ui accessibility notifications you
can post a bunch of those have to do
with
scrolling and making sure that your uh
that your user's position is
is uh up-to-date and consistent two more
that are actually pretty neat are
perform escape and perform magic tap now
these are these also have to do with
uh somewhat with specialized hardware
for perform escape this is for you
for dialogue so this allows if you have
a non-alert view dialog
if you're making a completely native
dialogue you can use
accessibility perform escape to dismiss
that dialogue and again there's
sometimes there's specialized hardware
for that but there's also specialized
gestures within voiceover just to say
dismiss whatever modal it exists uh
perform magic tap is
this is for uh for invoking sort of the
gestalt of your app
so like if you're a music if you're a
music app the
perform magic tap would play and pause
music and so again this is for
specialized hardware that has some
people can only interact with computer
using just a single button
and so this is w with that button press
that's what
usually gets invoked in your app is this
perform magic tab if you don't implement
these by default they just return no and
that reflects the success
of the actual thing so if you don't have
a
single purpose of your app if it's a big
enterprise app then perform magic tap
obviously isn't going to do anything and
that's okay
and finally ui accessibility focus is uh
is a way for you to track where the user
actually is
using uh within the app so while they're
navigating with ui access
with voiceovers so as you as you saw in
the video there were there you might
have seen
a little rectangle around the individual
uh elements that i was uh scrolling over
so i can
subscribe to these uh these uh
accessibility callbacks and get updated
and then
update my screen dynamically in response
to where the user actually is so i can
provide a
custom ui if maybe if somebody is
partial it doesn't have really strong
site
you could you could provide some
affordances for them
and then new in ios 7 this is actually
something that's uh
that's beyond just simple uh beyond
or is going to involve a larger audience
than than ordinary ui accessibility is
content size categories and so this is
for
just any people that just might not have
perfect 20 20 vision
need big that want bigger text in ios 7
they've added the ability to define
uh preferred text sizes and so it's uh
ui content size
medium large extra large extra extra
large and extra
extra large it's funny because they
literally spell out extra extra extra
large
in the variable name so that's
accessible by
settings general text size you get
programmatic access to it on ui
application and
uh the the downside is that you
basically if you're using a
if you're using a custom font you need
to manage this almost entirely yourself
you have to provide your own uh you have
to provide your own mapping between what
it means to be
extra extra large and what actual font
size that you're going to turn that into
and then you of course also need to make
sure that your layout flows properly in
response to that
the only if you're using auto layout and
you're using ui font
preferred font for text style then it
then it's going to uh
you're going to get it somewhat
automatically but that ui
the font that that you get from there is
system dependent right now i believe
it's helvetica new light
and so now we're going to do a seamless
transition over to android
uh so andra the android accessibility is
under the android dot accessibility
package
and uh basically for that you really
only need to implement for for simple
accessibility on android
just implement content description and
this is really not that hard this is
basically just like the accessibility
label
on uh on ios and android
all of the many controls that are
focusable and that are user interactable
like
uh text fields buttons they get some
kind of content description based on
their text but if you have
image buttons and this is something as
an android user and when i was trying to
play around with this and find a guinea
pig for uh for
building a third party accessibility
service
uh i discovered that a lot of apps are
just really bad at this and just do
they don't add they don't add content
descriptions onto their pictorial
buttons
so twitter for example on your profile
page the settings button doesn't have a
description on it
so when you click it the android
talkback just says button to you and
that's it and there's three of them
there's the
there's the settings there's switch
profile and you have no idea
what it is that you're doing if you
can't see the screen
um so this is available in android.view
set content description
if you want to do it programmatically or
you can just use the android content
description
attribute in your layouts then also you
have focus navigation so you should test
this with the d-pad in the simulator
um if you if your element is important
just this is basically just like
is accessibility element in ios just set
the
the item to be focusable again if it's
using if it is a user interactable
element then by default it is focusable
but for things like images stuff that's
really important to the user you want to
make it focusable
and again you can just call that with
view.setfocusable
oop come on there we go uh if you have a
complex
view navigation if you've got a really
complex uh business form if you're the
irs and you've got a w-4
then you want to implement some kind of
uh complex you may
you may have a view hierarchy that is
different
from the way that you defined it in your
layout so by default android is going to
infer from the way you declared your
layout the proper way to navigate your
app and if you've got something defined
defined with a weird layout then it may
not navigate in a natural way so what
you should do is
explicitly define what view you should
go to
after performing one of the focus
directions
from your view so it's not really that
hard to do you just got to go through
and make the effort to do it
uh so as for testing what you want to
use is
talk back and explore by touch on the
device so
this is this is just going to give you a
realistic uh
a realistic view of what um
what the user is going to go through on
on ios you actually have
a really neat feature that a lot it's
called a
screen the screen curtain and
essentially that blacks out the screen
and uh and forces you to interact with
the app just like a
a user with visual impairment would uh
and io
or on android unfortunately something
like that doesn't exist but you can
still
you it's still better to do it on a
device because that way yeah i suppose
you could like blind you you
could put uh put a mask on or something
to uh do that yourself
um but in my i i found that gestures
work a lot better on device than they do
on simulator and basically you're doing
all of your
uh all your exploration with gestures um
explore by touch isn't present by
default in the emulator however
you can install the apk yourself it's
really not that hard to do and then it
does work
it's a little jittery but then again the
emulator is basically jittery all the
time so it's not really a whole lot new
you also need to make sure that talkback
works with gestures so
scrolling or zooming talkback uses a lot
of gestures itself and generally
speaking
the talkback gestures are the same to
perform scrolling and zooming
or scrolling are the same as regular
gestures in that
you're just using one figure except with
talkback you're using two fingers
it's not really that big of a deal now
zooming is a little bit more complicated
and you're probably
not going to be able to replace the
zooming feature with gestures you're
going to need to add buttons or
something else and you can actually
discover that
talkback is running and then you can
present those selectively
also you need to make sure that your
focusable controls are a minimum of 48dp
that's just a that's a human interface
guideline requirement for android and
it just means that it's a lot more
likely it's a user is actually going to
be able to discover your control
so now this is the really cool thing
this is what really got me excited with
accessibility on android was
accessibility services
so you can augment third-party
applications this kind of this is
really illustrates the difference
between
the ios and android philosophies on ios
they give you a
really really powerful screen reader and
voiceover can do
a lot of amazing stuff and it even
interfaces with some hardware
but you can't extend it in any way like
you get options that you can declare
with your accessibility elements and it
and you get actually your accessibility
elements on ios can
can be marked up and have a lot
more different behavior than they can on
android however
with android you can just toss the
entire system out that they provide for
you by default and write
and write your own it's pretty neat so
you get to walk that you can walk the
entire android accessibility down by
yourself
respond to user actions and respond to
notifications uh and in fact
you don't you uh you can actually
responding to notifications is really
easy and you don't even have to
walk the entire screen you get the raw
notification data because the
notification is just a bundle
and then you can use that to forward it
off to other devices that's actually how
pebble uh implements some of its uh
functionality with its watch
that was the very first accessibility
service that i wrote was
at jive we have an android app and for
my hack day
for a hack day project that we got to do
we do four of those a quarter
or sorry we do four of those per year
once per quarter i didn't want to have
to
add accessibility notifications into uh
or pebble notifications into the app
because then that would require a whole
new push to production and testing
so instead i just augmented it with a
completely separate third-party service
that didn't require any separate uh any
new push of our code and testers never
had to work with it it's a completely
separate apk that has exactly one user
um so when you're building your
third-party accessibility service you
need to
this is your this is how you'll lay it
out with your android xml it's basically
mostly the boilerplate the
the important things are that you need
to buy you need to declare
bind accessibility service permission
you need to
you need to register for the
accessibility service intent
and then you need to add this metadata
call which is going to declare this this
is basically the only way that you can
configure yourself to read from the
screen you can actually
other things you declare in this
metadata file you can programmatically
alter but
screen uh screen reading you have to
explicitly state
in the xml file and this is new with
uh with ice cream sandwich uh the the
ability to read from the screen a lot
the basic content description stuff has
been there since donut but
uh the good stuff in third party
accessibility services i believe is api
14.
um so then in the accessibility service
config xml this is where you actually
declare what your service does
and how it interacts with the user so
we're going to go through uh
at a high level what the or what the
different attributes are the really
important one here is can retrieve
window content this is the one that you
have to declare
that you have to declare in your
accessibility file it's required for dom
access
if you if you don't have this declared
then all of your dom
all of your dom requests are going to
come back as nil
description this is what the user is
actually going to see when they
when they see your service listed within
the accessibility options on android
notification timeout is the amount of
time between notification events so like
as a user is dragging around on the
screen
you might get many no you could
potentially get many many notification
events coming back
uh about the different uh elements
they've touched so they recommend a time
out of a hundred and that's what i used
um package names is a comma separated
list
of all of the actually we'll go go ahead
and get into that next slide
the settings activity is a activity that
you can present on the settings screen
and that allows the users
to that's going to allow the users to
configure your service in some way i
didn't need one for what i did
the package names are comma separated
list of the uh
all the packages that your service
augments so you can use
android the literal android word if you
want to automate
the system package so i was trying to
use that to
augment my lock screen to audit to
programmatically unlock my lock screen
when it turned on but unfortunately the
samsung touchwiz lock screen
is uh is not accessible the buttons are
not declared as focusable so it's
really unfortunate um you can discover
your system packages with this simple
adb
shell and uh that way then you can you
know you might not know what the package
name of the app you want to use is so in
my case i augmented the guidebook app
which is the app we're using here at
strangeloop
i didn't know what its package was
called so you can just list it out and
it's pretty obvious it was like
com.guidebook.android i think
the accessibility event types these are
all the things you can respond to so you
don't have to
this is just basically like a filter so
if you only care about
when the user focuses on something or
when the user clicks on something you
can get that
in my case i just went ahead and used
the type all mask because i had a bunch
of different ones that i wanted to use
and the feedback type i'm not sure that
this is actually required to be accurate
i haven't really seen this actually used
in any of the ui
but uh i just go ahead and and uh
declare that my
that my service was an audible feedback
that's what it provided
then the accessibility flags these are
ways that you can get more advanced
features out of the accessibility
service
so you can if you're a
if you're a test runner for example you
can declare that you want to report view
ids
what that does is uh gives you fully
qualified names of all your view ids
you can i'm not actually sure what
request enhanced web accessibility does
i've looked for documentation on it and
i couldn't really find a whole lot
request touch exploration mode this
basically just says my accessibility
service is only useful if you use
explore by touch and there's also some
more advanced features that require this
flag to be set uh this is all in the
documentation
uh when you're actually writing
accessibility service now we're getting
into the real meat of the actual
class uh we have uh on service connected
this is the setup method this gets
called once when your service starts up
similarly on unbind that gets called
when your service shuts down
i use this to fire up the text to speech
engine uh which i used to speak
uh the speak the values that i hovered
over
on accessibility event is a required
method and that gets called when your
actual accessibility event is received
and then on interrupt gets called if
your if your service is stopped in the
middle of performing accessibility
events because the user navigated away
or something like that
you can also get on gesture and on key
event this will give you when you
when you're subscribing to gestures on
keyevent is when uh if you want to
build a build a shortcut service you can
actually
intercept every key press before it goes
through the system and consume them if
you want
um other the handy methods and objects
as part of this
uh as part of the system accessibility
event obviously that's the thing you're
getting when you get the on
accessibility event
uh that has the uh the source which if
you again if you don't declare that you
need window access
can be nil the accessibility node info
that's the actual accessibility dom
element so that's got all the
information about is it clickable is it
focusable
what is the content description you know
what what should i read back to the user
things like that
uh accessibility or service get root
active in or we get root and active
window that gives you the
that's like uh you know document.getbody
that's the top level
of the uh dom of the accessibility dom
and from there you can walk the entire
tree and get everything you want
and again that can be null as well so
you just need to make sure every time
you get a
accessibility node from the service you
need to make sure that it's not null or
you're just throwing all pointers
one other really neat thing is
accessibility node info perform action
so this is where you can actually do
things on behalf of the user
this is really cool so basically it's
most of the user interaction
that can be performed you can do
programmatically it's this isn't an
extensive list i left out like four
things just in the interest of
you being able to read the slide so for
the demo
i didn't use the strange loop guide
because the strange loop guide wasn't
available when i wrote this
so as you navigate through this is the
screen
in this is the screen without
accessibility
or without talk back turned on this is
the screen with talkback turned on there
is a yellow rectangle
highlighted around the overall rating if
you actually if you
accessibility hover on the element
unfortunately
when you hover on that it is not
declared as it doesn't have a con
description it's not declared as a
button which it actually is
so you don't get any kind of useful
feedback um
when you actually tap it then you get
the my you get a my rating
call out and you can actually view what
the overall rating is and you can rate
it
so and again if i if i hover on overall
then it actually will speak back to me
exactly what was said
so this is the way it behaves by default
so see how it say if you get the my you
get the my rating call out no big deal
then we'll go to the next one this is
with explore by touch turned on
whoops
general info
notice we get the feedback that we
touched something but we didn't hear it
didn't tell us what that thing was
overall 2.673 votes and that's what
that's the behavior i would expect when
i when i hovered over there
i would get the actual feedback of what
what the rating was
so that's what i did with the
accessibility service is it is when you
tap that button then it programmatically
uh touches the touches the button brings
up the call
out navigates through the dom finds that
overall label
and then uh and then captures the
overall label's value and uses the
screen reader to read that back to the
user
general info overall
2.673 votes general info
and basically for as far as strategies
for actually writing something like this
you it you just have to sort of
construct a parallel state machine
because all you're getting you're
getting an event stream from
the system so you have to do sort of
sort of like sax parsing
strategies when you're dealing with xmls
you've got to build up a uh
you've got to build up your own
programmatic dom that exists and you've
got to be ready for that to all go away
at any time if the
if the windows contents drastically
change or if the
or if your system's interrupted so it's
just really an exercise in creating
state machines which
you can go to many other talks and
they'll give you really great advice on
how to do that
then i've also got a giant load of
links here um the if you're interested
in the actual implementation of
this stuff it's on uh it's on github you
should be able to
just download the accessibility project
with eclipse and run it on your device
and you can
uh and you can interact with it um one
other one i want to call out
specifically is google's
eyes free code project this has a lot of
great source and a lot of great apks you
can install
and also uh matt gemel's um sort of
magnum opus on accessibility for iphone
this is a a couple a few thousand word
essay and
uh really great and he's a really great
accessibility guy
i think i've got a little bit of time
for questions maybe
anybody okay oh yes
yeah okay so the question was about uh
accessibility localization you actually
can there is an accessibility value for
the accessibility language
and then it's up to you actually to
programmatically uh
they don't have as far as i know they
don't have localized bundles but you can
programmatically define a label properly
according to the language
okay i think we're done thank you